Após 15 dias de antibiótico forte, qual
indicação para fortalecer o sistema
imunológico? Bem, vou dar aqui algumas
dicas, né? Depois que você usa
antibiótico por um tempo longo,
prolongado, o sistema de defesa imune e
a microbiota ficam comprometidos por até
2 anos. Veja só, ó o tempo longo, de 6
meses a 2 anos. Então, pra gente poder
restaurar isso, é importante você comer
as fibras, que são os prebióticos, são
as comidas, as bactérias boas. Aí temos
aí o consumo de 21 a 38 g de fibras
diárias, cebola, alho, banana, aspargos,
aveia, leguminosas, fermentados como
quinchi, kefir, natô.
Evite açúcares simples e gorduras
artificiais que vão aumentar a
inflamação. Então, vamos falar de
suplementação. Você pode usar
probióticos específicos para recolonizar
a mucosa intestinal. Você pode usar
vitamina C clássica e o zinco, né, que
dão suporte ao sistema imune como
antioxidantes. Você pode usar o Epicor,
que é a combinação de betaglucanos com
vitaminas e minerais que vão melhorar o
seu sistema imune inato. Você pode
utilizar o colossro bovino, que é rico
em anticorpos, você pode usar o própolis
verde ou outras variedades para
estimular os macróficos, células de
defesa e os linfócitos, outra célula de
defesa. E o astragal equinácia também
vão ser úteis pra regulação imune.
Hábitos fundamentais: regulação do
estresse, sono de 7 a 9 horas para
regeneração imunológica, exercícios
regulares moderados, mesmo que seja
somente 30 minutos de caminhada por dia,
hidratação mínima de 2 L a 2,5 L diários
e obviamente, né, evitar o tabagismo, o
consumo de alimentos ultraprocessados e
manter o seu peso adequado. Então, a
recuperação pós antibióticos vai exigir
então que você faça tudo isso em
conjunto, principalmente cuidando dos
hábitos de vida, que são muito mais
importantes ainda do que a
suplementação, mas que pode ser feita
sim de maneira direcionada,
individualizada, com acompanhamento
médico ser possível para restaurar
completamente a sua homeostase
imunológica e microbiana. Um grande
abraço. Boa sorte. Yeah.